Alright. So, let's see how we can add 1/3 of strawberry icing and 1/2 of vanilla
icing together. I need a way to compare 1/3 and 1/2 of the cake. If I cut the
cake into equal size pieces for both of them, then I could add the parts
together. Let's split up our cake into sixths. I'm going to split every third
into to two equal parts. Doing that, I can see I get 2/6 of the cake is covered
in strawberry icing. So, how did I get from 1/3 to 2/3? We doubled the number of
pieces we had altogether, I went from 3 pieces to 6. So, I know I needed to
multiply the denominator by 2. I also doubled the number of pieces I had. I had
1 out of 3 and now, I have 2 out of 6. Notice I'm multiplying by the number 1, 2
divided by 2 is still 1. I'm just changing what this fraction looks like, I'm
not changing its value. We can still see 1/3 is 2/6. I'm going to use the same
approach to make 1/2 into sixths. I'm going to split up this cake into 6. To
change from halves to sixths, I need to multiply by 3 over 3. I know 2 times 3
gives me 6. And then for the numerator, 1 times 3 is 3. Visually, I can see that
1/2 of the cake frosted in vanilla icing is the same as 3/6 of the cake also
frosted in vanilla icing. I multiplied by 1 here, so I'm not changing the value
of this fraction, I'm just changing what it looks like. Now that I have my cake
split up into sixths, I have 2/6 of it frosted in strawberry, and 3/6 of it
frosted in vanilla icing. Now, I can just add my sixths together. I have the
same sized pieces, so I can just count them up. I can see that 2/6 and 3/6,
altogether, makes 5/6. And here's what it would look like on one cake. I have
half of it covered in vanilla icing and 1/3 of it covered in strawberry icing.
This would be 1/6 of the cake, 2/6 of the cake, 3/6 of the cake, 4/6 of the
cake, and 5/6 of the cake. So, when my fractions were just 1/3 and 1/2, I
couldn't add them together. I had to get a common denominator first. I had to
get them into the same size pieces. So, how do I add fract ions together once I
have a common denominator? Let's try this with a quiz.